Europe hasn't had a hurricane reach its
Shore in over 50 years now don't get the
wrong idea
hurricane season still brings a hefty
dose of wind and rain but Europe has
something that North America does it
when it comes to protection against
hurricanes location hurricanes usually
form off the coast of West Africa where
warm water near the equator and high
humidity create columns of rapidly
rising rotating air it's the perfect
recipe for a storm now the more warm
moist air that the system picks up the
stronger it becomes
that's why tropical storms can quickly
grow into a full-on hurricane as it
marches across the Atlantic now normally
hurricanes are propelled on a westward
track by the trade winds caused by the
Earth's rotation
that's why Europe as well as the west
coast of the US rarely experienced
full-on hurricanes but that's not the
whole story after all since the year
2000 remnants of around 30 hurricanes
have reached Europe for comparison
Florida has seen 79 real hurricanes over
the same time frame by the time these
remnants make landfall they've went from
a hurricane force to a tropical storm or
weaker that's where Europe's location
comes into play in order for a hurricane
to head towards Europe something crucial
has to happen it has to travel really
far north by about 200 miles once a
storm system reaches 30 degrees north it
encounters the subtropical jet stream
which moves in the opposite direction of
the trade winds and therefore blows the
storm East but because the storm is now
farther north the waters underneath are
colder by up to about five to ten
degrees Celsius which means less energy
available to feed the storm and as a
result it starts to die down by the time
it's headed for Europe
even though it's no longer hurricane it
still packs a punch when it hits shore
in fact most of these hurricane remnants
will combine with other nearby cyclones
and weather fronts that create high
winds and rain that mainly hit Ireland
and Great Britain but have been known to
reach as far as Greece or even farther
in northern Russia typical damages
include power outages flooding and
occasionally casualties most recently
the remnants of Hurricane Ophelia made
landfall in Ireland and Scotland in 2017
about 50,000 households in Northern
Ireland lost power three deaths were
reported and down trees closed many of
the public roads and highways this was
the worst storm that Ireland had seen in
50 years and it may be a sign of what's
to come
as global surface temperatures rise it
will also increase the sea surface
temperatures in the northern Atlantic
which researchers estimate could
contribute to an increase in the number
of hurricane-force storms that reach
Europe some experts predict that by the
end of the 21st century Europe had
experienced on average 13 powerful
storms each year during hurricane season
compared to the two per year it sees now
you